in spite of searches from the air london
sea there has been no sighting of the
shark since the fatal attack
underwater traps and bait have been laid
to try to lure it in
simon nellist originally from the uk had
been in the ocean off sydney's coast on
wednesday
training for a charity swim
oh no
that's insane
people on nearby rocks could do nothing
to help
i just uh
some guy was swimming
shah came and attacked him vertically
we heard a yell and then
turned around like it looked like a car
just landed in the water big splash
the 35 year old who was engaged to be
married suffered catastrophic injuries
from the shark that's believed to be at
least three meters long
the news hit
us like a truck
because he's really you know one of the
people who made this earth better
beaches around the area were temporarily
closed with people told to stay out of
the sea
yeah it was pretty traumatizing
hearing about it but uh
yeah look you just go in
going for a quick dip and in and out and
yeah it wasn't too much of an issue but
yeah still pretty uh pretty traumatizing
um we just came for an early swim and so
i walked down to the beach they hadn't
closed it yet so i jumped in for a
little bit i was aware of the shark
attack and i just jumped in for a bit
came out and then the lifeguards came up
and closed the beach
the charity swim event that simon was
training for has been cancelled
he is the victim of the first fatal
shark attack in this part of new south
wales for 60 years
lee styled sky news